for more on all this let's bring in
Texas Senator John Cornyn he joins us
this morning senator good morning thanks
for being here good morning
always good to see you alright so let's
look at some of these businesses that
are reopening in Texas on Friday you
just heard it retail stores restaurants
movie theaters libraries even museums do
you believe this is the right timing
that Texas can reopen some of these
businesses as soon as this week well
Sandra there is no playbook for this
this is unprecedented and I know
governor Abbott is consulting with the
best minds the the experts to try to
guide his decision-making but to me the
key is nobody's forced to open up but
they can gradually subject to these
guidelines and we're gonna then hit the
pause button see how it's going before
we proceed to open up some more but
nobody believes a we can stay locked
down and hunker down in our homes
isolated forever and of course we heard
from Governor Abbott as well that while
some of those businesses will reopen and
also the museums and libraries social
distancing measures will need to
continue to take place those that
operations that will not reopen are
Jim's barbershops Hair Salons bars
tattoo parlors so what senator criteria
do you think needs to be met in order to
decide okay phase two let's start
opening some of these other businesses
well I believe that the reason we did
the initial lockdown is primarily to
protect our hospitals from giving over
overrun with Kovac 19 patients so they
were told no elective surgery you have
to leave your beds open you have to
leave your ICU available and as well as
ventilators now that it looks like these
mitigation efforts have bent the curve I
think the governor is wisely and our
mayor's are doing the same thing at the
local level
trying to see okay can we can we take a
first step - we stick our big toe in the
water and see how that works I think
we're going to be guided by what the
experience is and what the
reaction is because obviously public
health public safety comes first next
the question becomes those small
businesses that have not been able to
make it through this that are continuing
to struggle and especially those that
haven't been able to reopen or or won't
this week here's a Fox Business calm
article on stimulus phase four you've
heard a lot of the talk about it senator
coronavirus stimulus phase four could
exceed one trillion dollars and include
negative payroll tax would you be able
to support that and do you think it's
got a chance at passing Sandra I think
it's premature to consider what
additional steps we might take because
we've just spent roughly 2.8 trillion
dollars and as you might expect any time
you do anything this big and that's fast
and again this is unprecedented there's
going to be some bumps there's going to
be some problem so what I'd like to do
is see how well what we've already done
meets the need and then be guided by by
by what we learn I think it's premature
to talk about a trillion dollars more
added to the national debt got it
meanwhile Mitch McConnell has been
getting some criticism for comments that
he made suggesting bankruptcy for some
states rather than federal bailouts the
president also agreeing with that
questioning in a tweet why would we
bailout some of these states that were
already struggling before this hit
governor jay Inslee from Washington is
the latest to criticize those that
suggestion from Mitch McConnell let's
listen together and I'll get your
reaction we are hopeful that Congress
will roundly reject senator McConnell's
suggestion that the way to deal with
this is to allow States go bankrupt that
is the most wrongheaded ludicrous idea
I've heard for a long long time so
senator what was your reaction to that
suggestion from Mitch McConnell well I
think I think it was largely
unfortunately misinterpreted I think
what Senator McConnell was trying to say
or what he did say is there are limits
to the extent the federal government can
pay the bills for state and local
government they are
are sovereign they have their own tax
base they have their own budgets and
some states we know are notoriously bad
about not balancing their budgets and
having large unfunded public sector
Union the pension plans for example we
are more than happy to do what's
necessary to deal with this virus this
is an emergency that's why you've seen
this unprecedented financial support for
states and local government but at some
point we're gonna have to have a serious
conversation about what those limits are
because the federal government can't
continue to spend money and not an add
to our national debt and deficits
because that in and of itself can create
a dangerous situation
well senator Cornyn that is a debate
surely that we will see continued to
heat up in Washington among other things
including another possible round of
stimulus our best to your state we will
be watching closely as things start to
reopen there in Texas and we hope to
have you back soon senator thank you so
much